bitcoin's up 60 year-to-date gold is not
why is gold going down in price and what
do you think happens to bitcoin's price
through the end of the year
well again you know
there's only a few months left i know
most of you guys think a hundred
thousand i mean that's pretty much been
the standard you know 100 000 by the end
of the year and i think a lot of you are
still clinging to that uh i guess it's
possible you know i knew right you know
i think i was on your show or somebody
showed i said yeah i think it's possible
bitcoin can go to a hundred thousand
then i'm reading all these headlines
peter schiff forecast 100 000 bitcoin
right so
you know i actually think it's it's it's
not likely to hit a hundred thousand so
i think it's more likely not to go there
and obviously you know there's only a
few months of the year left uh for it to
do that uh but i guess if i was just
gonna flip a coin up or down on bitcoin
i mean i guess i'd pick down you know
but i mean i mean it could be up uh but
you know i think the market for bitcoin
to me again
uh looks toppy once again i mean we just
had this huge pump and dump over el
salvador you know everybody was excited
everybody was buying and solidarity and
you know and then all of a sudden the
day of the el salvador inaugurates
bitcoin and there's one hour and there's
a massive dump and the price goes from
you know 52 000 uh down to whatever 42
000 whatever was almost or over a 15
drop in under an hour
uh and so that might have been a a key
reversal uh that day uh that week uh you
know we'll see how this month uh uh
looks but i thought last week was a
technically very weak uh week for
bitcoin
and peter and so it may end up you know
getting you know finishing the year
closer to that 30 000 support uh than
the 50 000 resistance uh and it's also
possible that it could break below that
and and go much lower i mean if it
doesn't do it by the end of this year i
think it's going to do it eventually i
mean i think this is a bubble uh as well
as the other 12 000 uh some odd
cryptocurrencies that that that
currently exists uh and that compete
with bitcoin peter
yeah
if bitcoin breaks 100k this year you
have to fly to miami in that shirt that
exact shirt i want you to wear and i'll
take you to dinner
if bitcoin doesn't break 100k by the end
of the year i'll buy a lot of gold
why don't you since you're gonna have so
much money if bitcoins at a hundred
thousand why don't you fly down here and
take me to dinner down here in puerto
rico because no that's the whole point
is you have to come to me no no no the
loser comes to the winner that's how
this works is you gotta come to me when
that happens
but um are you in what are you what are
you gonna do if it doesn't hit a hundred
thousand bucks i'll buy some gold
satisfied help me
that that helps you i mean even if you
buy it from shift gold our commissions
are so low you know
it doesn't really do me any good all
right i got my two brothers here they
got questions for you and then i'll
finish you off in a second go ahead
peter that was good i appreciate you uh
giving him a couple ribbings there uh
my question would be
what would have to happen if anything uh
kind of for bitcoin and the bitcoin
network for you to change your mind in
reverse course
yeah you know i answered that question
on somebody else's show and then
somebody you know took it out of context
and made a video out of it to try to say
that i'm endorsing bitcoin because i i i
talked about all the things that haven't
happened to bitcoin that if they did
happen well then i you know would
probably have to change my mind but you
know none of those things have actually
happened yet
uh but you know again what would have to
happen is bitcoin would actually have to
succeed
as money right so i would have to see
a a demonstration and like even if you
just took el salvador for example right
because i mean hey that's legal tender
if i actually saw
like el salvador function
let's say for
a i don't know how a longer period of
time but where
everything was priced in bitcoin forget
dollars
you got a salary it was expressed in
bitcoin
you rented an apartment your rent was in
bitcoin not that you paid it in bitcoin
that you figured out what the bitcoin
equivalent was for a dollar that when
you actually rented your apartment your
monthly payments were fixed in a
quantity of bitcoin right uh you're so
salaries are in bitcoin rents are fixed
in bitcoin uh you know you you go out
and buy an insurance policy the premium
is in bitcoin the benefits are paid in
bitcoin right you have a whole world
where bitcoin is used exclusively where
nobody tries to do a calculation well
you know what what is the dollar value
of this right when you go into a store
in america and something is ten dollars
you don't try to calculate in your head
like what does that mean in terms of
other things it's like ten dollars is
ten dollars that's the price right so
you you'd have to be able to transact in
bitcoin in that kind of world where i
could make you alone uh or you know pomp
can come to me and say peter i i need a
loan can you lend me a bitcoin i'll pay
you back you know in five years i'll
give you the same bitcoin and i'll give
you a you know five percent interest a
year in bitcoin i mean we have to be
able to agree on a loan where the only
thing in the loan was bitcoin so if we
could actually get to a world where
bitcoin can function because
you know we're in a world right now
where the dollar functions like that we
used to live in a world where gold
functioned like that you know where all
these things were done all these
calculations were in gold everything was
priced in gold whether the gold was
represented by dollars or not even when
the goal was represented by dollars the
dollars were fixed to gold so those
calculations were still there so if
bitcoin can actually be a medium of
exchange a unit account
uh and a store value all at once and
does that over time then i'd have to say
i guess i was wrong about bitcoin but i
mean we're not even close to to
that happening what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're gonna be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you 10 in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com
to get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]